Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Jules Daunay
Mon projet se rapporte
à ces idées inventives,
modestes :
qui peuvent soit améliorer
notre confort au quotidien,
ou apporter de réelles solutions
pour mieux partager nos ressources.
Parmi ces multitudes d'idées inventives,
il en est une en particulier
dont je voudrais vous parler ce soir,
car elle concerne un élément absolument
vital dont nous sommes tous dépendants,
et dont la disponibilité
est préoccupante :
l'eau.
L'eau est aujourd'hui appelée
l'or bleu tant elle est rare.
Et pourtant la planète est
recouverte à 70% d'eau.
Dit comme ça, ça paraît énorme,
Et,
vu d'une manière plus proportionnelle
par rapport à la taille du globe,
ça donne ça.
C'est beaucoup moins impressionnant.
De ses 70 % de couverture,
3 % seulement n'est pas de l'eau salée.
Et de ces 3 %,
les deux tiers sont sous forme de glace –
les glaciers, les banquises,
les neiges éternelles.
Au final,
une minuscule petite sphère que
vous distinguez à peine en dessous,
qui fait 60 km de diamètre,
constitue le réservoir d'eau disponible
pour le vivant sur la planète.
Le vivant, c'est donc l'humain,
mais aussi l'animal et le végétal.
Et cette petite sphère est en danger.
Chaque année nous livre
son lot de nouvelles alarmantes :
les températures, la montée
du niveau des océans,
ont battu des records en 2015,
faisant de cette année la pire
de toute l'histoire moderne.
Une tendance qui semble se confirmer
en 2016 puisque les six
premiers mois de cette année
ont été de loin les plus chauds
jamais enregistrés sur le globe.
L'ONU estime qu'en 2025,
dans moins de dix ans,
c'est-à-dire demain,
63 % de la population mondiale
sera confrontée à un stress hydrique.
Autrement dit,
une réserve d'eau insuffisante
pour subvenir aux simples besoins vitaux
d'une partie de l'humanité.
Face à cela, certains gouvernements
ont pris la décision de légiférer
pour nous imposer une réduction
de notre consommation d'eau.
Après six années de sécheresse,
l'État de Californie est un pionnier
dans ces prises de décision extrêmes.
D'autres nations sont
en cours de réflexion.
Et si aucune solution cohérente
et abordable n'est trouvée rapidement,
ce choix va s'imposer de lui-même
pour tenter d'éviter des conflits
liés à la pénurie d'eau.
Face à cette réalité,
nous devons tous prendre
conscience de l'urgence absolue
de rationaliser notre consommation d'eau,
tout au moins cesser de la gaspiller.
L'irrigation des cultures à elle seule
utilise 80% de notre réservoir
d'eau douce planétaire,
les 20% restants étant consommés
par l'homme et l'industrie.
La solution qui coule
de source, si j'ose dire,
est donc dans la rationalisation
de cette eau d'irrigation.
Si nous parvenons à économiser
ne fût-ce que 10% de ces 80%,
alors nous sommes en mesure
d'inverser une tendance qui apparaît
aujourd'hui comme inexorable.
Les technologies modernes
permettent d'économiser de l'eau,
elles permettent
d'économiser beaucoup d'eau
en donnant aux plantes
juste ce dont elles ont besoin.
Grâce à ces solutions technologiques,
des essais scientifiques ont démontré
qu'on était en capacité d'économiser
jusqu'à 50 % d'eau
par rapport à une irrigation gérée
stupidement par des horloges programmées,
ces programmateurs
que vous connaissez tous.
Le problème étant avec ces solutions –
On se dit que finalement
la solution est là,
qu'on a trouvé, mais non,
ce n'est pas si simple
parce que ces solutions high tech sont
d'une part très compliquées à utiliser,
et d'autre part – et c'est plus grave –
elles sont inaccessibles
financièrement à 95 % des utilisateurs.
Ces solutions technologiques
sont donc réservées à de rares oasis,
telles que nos splendides greens de golf.
Il existe d'autres solutions dont une
que j'ai développée et mise au point
et qui conforte le fait que les
solutions technologiques ont une limite,
en termes de coûts et de complexité,
par rapport aux résultats attendus.
Cette solution que j'ai mise au point
est une solution dite
de basse technologie, low tech,
et permettez-moi de vous convaincre
en vous racontant une petite histoire.
D'abord peut-être je me présente
encore une fois : Bernard Balet,
je suis –
je baigne depuis une trentaine d'années
dans la mécanique artistique des fluides,
je suis né et j'ai grandi
les pieds dans le sol,
un peu créatif certainement,
un peu rêveur aussi,
et conscient qu'on n'a qu'une seule maison
et qu'il faut éviter qu'elle brûle,
donc il faut trouver des solutions.
Il y a quelques décennies de cela,
un proche parent possédait
une bergerie en Haute-Provence –
dans le sud de la France donc –
accrochée à la montagne, dans la rocaille.
Cette bergerie était enrichie
d'une petite cuvette limoneuse,
un terrain propice à des cultures.
Et un trésor sur place :
une source qui coulait
depuis le haut de la montagne.
L'eau était canalisée jusqu'au cabanon.
C'était une eau qui coulait
à profusion toute l'année.
L'isolement du lieu ne permettant pas
de raccordement au réseau électrique,
et son propriétaire ne venant profiter
de sa villégiature que deux mois par an,
il m'a été confié de trouver
une solution pour maintenir
le potager en bon état de production,
mais de manière autonome, évidemment.
Sans quoi j'allais me retrouver condamné
à monter à pied dans la montagne
tous les matins arroser son foutu potager,
et ça, il n'en était pas question.
Comment je m'y suis pris ?
J'ai pris une vanne, tout simplement,
que j'ai raccordée
à l'arrivée d'eau de cette source,
Une vanne avec une manette,
un simple quart de tour,
à laquelle j'ai connecté en
son milieu une barre de fer
avec du fil de fer, j'ai noué ça,
et ça constituait un balancier qui
permettait d'ouvrir et de fermer l'eau.
D'un côté du balancier,
j'ai installé un contrepoids,
et de l'autre, des grosses
éponges de ménage
en prenant soin que l'ensemble du système
se trouve sous le rayon d'arrosage
d'un des asperseurs du jardin.
Si bien que,
lorsque le jardin était arrosé,
mes éponges l'étaient aussi,
elles s'alourdissaient
du poids de l'eau, et finalement,
basculaient ma manette et ma vanne
en position de fermeture de l'arrosage.
Ensuite, selon le climat,
très simplement, les éponges
s'évaporaient, s'allégeaient de leur eau,
exactement de la même manière
que le sol concerné,
et finalement, refaisaient basculer
dans le sens de l'ouverture
d'un nouveau cycle d'irrigation.
Nous obtenions là un système simple,
peu coûteux s'il en est,
de contrôle climatique de l'arrosage.
Après six mois d'absence,
nous sommes revenus sur les lieux
et nous avons constaté que le rendement
du potager avait littéralement explosé.
L'expérience a en outre démontré,
tout à fait accessoirement,
que ce système économisait de l'eau,
alors même que dans les années 80,
l'idée d'une pénurie globale d'eau
liée à un réchauffement climatique
tenait de la science-fiction
tout au moins,
sinon du pur délire.
Depuis ces dernières années,
j'ai affiné ce système
pour le rendre accessible à tous,
utilisable sous toutes les latitudes
et en tout saisonnalité.
La barre de fer, le balancier,
le fil de fer rouillé,
ont été remplacés maintenant
par une vanne magnétique
qui est actionnée
par un aimant permanent –
une énergie gratuite
pour des milliers d'années –
lequel aimant est associé à un flotteur.
Très simple.
Les éponges ont été remplacées
par un élément en céramique poreuse,
beaucoup plus compact
et ayant une meilleure réponse
par rapport à la demande réelle des sols.
L'ensemble est adaptable à tous les types
et toutes les tailles de cultures,
est peu coûteux et ne nécessite
aucune connexion électrique,
donc adaptable aux pays dits en voie de
développement qui en ont le plus besoin.
Le système s'installe en mode
plug and play sur un réseau d'irrigation.
J'aime le mot « plug and play »,
ça fait très high tech.
Ce système est opérationnel
ici en Nouvelle-Calédonie ;
il a été mis en test auprès
de l'institut agronomique calédonien,
sous sa supervision –
un test comparatif qui a permis
de démontrer une économie de 34 % d'eau
par rapport à un système programmé,
pourtant réglé au plus juste
par des scientifiques.
Un autre test vient juste de se terminer
sur les espaces verts
de la ville de Nouméa.
Et là, nous avons pu démontrer
une économie d'eau
de plus de 70% par rapport
à la programmation actuelle.
Si vous passez devant,
vous constaterez que les pelouses
sont au moins aussi vertes qu'avant.
Cette solution a reçu
le prix de l'innovation
au salon international de l'irrigation
de Los Angeles en novembre dernier.
Pour moi, ça a été
une chance extraordinaire
car ça m'a ouvert, dès le lendemain, des
portes jusque-là hermétiquement closes.
J'ai été reçu par [l'entité] californienne
en charge de l'eau, le Water Boards,
qui m'a fait part de son réel intérêt
pour cette solution
de par sa simplicité,
son autonomie et son coût.
Et cela m'a ouvert les portes
d'universités spécialisées en irrigation,
comme les universités
de Davis et de Riverside.
Et des tests maintenant sont
en marche pour être performés,
pour être publiés dans
des revues scientifiques.
Je suis en contact actuellement
aussi avec des entités internationales
comme l'ONU
parce que je suis convaincu,
mais je dois aussi convaincre,
qu'un système aussi simple que celui-là,
qui défie les systèmes
de haute technologie,
est capable en toute humilité
d'apporter sa petite goutte d'eau
à un rééquilibrage hydrique global.
Pour finir,
je voudrais partager un rêve avec vous.
Essayez d'imaginer ce même système
sur une échelle bien plus vaste,
en plein milieu d'un désert,
puisque le caractère autonome
du système le permet,
où
une sélection de graines
de plantes annuelles,
de buissons et d'arbres,
pourrait germer, croître, s'étendre,
recréer un écosystème, devenir une forêt
qui ramènerait naturellement la pluie.
Je travaille sur ce projet actuellement.
En attendant, le temps est compté,
et nous devons tous
changer nos comportements,
sinon le changement nous sera imposé.
(Applaudissements)